I've been working till the break of 4:45
I get an automatic raise and I can't be
fine must wait till age 57 till I can
retire with an inflation adjusted
pension that continuously keeps going
high oh it's a damn shame what the
world's come to they want us back in the
office on Mondays too wish I could just
wake up and it not be true but it is oh
it is is not living in the real
world is a lot harder than youd know
sure I got Dental but it's bad I go
menal cuz I had to fill out both of
these forms I also see price Hicks on
Necessities I had to purchase my rental
in Ocean City please don't tell anyone
it's so embarrassing the plight of rich
man